e
e e
[Music]
princess
that's
right good evening I'd like to call the
finance committee meeting to order
for uh October
14th and the first item to talk about is
going to be uh temporary resolution
107 days
24 a resolution to
approve then and th certificates for
payment of invoices to sh company out of
the 3 mil Street Levy improve
Improvement fund 209 and the general
Improvement fund 3016 and to declare an
emergency this is coming from the public
works commissioner or committee and uh
councilman tener yes this is uh we
talked about this in uh our committee
meeting and I believe it was in August
uh and this is uh Shelly had had done um
projects for us and it's really weird
they Wen paid it's just kind of weird
after they do that they expect payment
so that's really all this is for and
we're just going to
suspend and your second is Mr lenberg
thank you uh any
questions any issues with
suspension then we will suspend this
moving forward the next item is
temporary resolution
10824 a resolution to appoint a business
representative to the board of directors
of the viol township city of Lancaster
joint Economic Development
district and it's coming from the law
committee and
councilman yes thank you um there's been
a request to expand the Jed and if it's
approved the Board needs to include a
business representative and this is for
that appointment um law director Hall I
didn't know if you had anything
additional you wanted to
add yeah um Violet Township has asked us
to appoint uh William Vince utterbach
specifically because um he is one of the
only very few employees in Violet
Township in the Jed at this time um so
there's really nobody else that
qualifies at the moment but he is also
um a really great guy um he is the uh
Township administrator and their
Economic Development specialist as well
so he worked all the way through the Jed
with us and probably has the most
knowledge about it um of anyone so
that's why they've asked for him to be
appointed and I think they spoke with
the mayor about that and he was board as
well so
thanks and Mr bisj is my second we'll go
three readings three readings
questions thank you next item is
temporary resolution 109
d24 resolution to authorize allocating
American Rescue plan funds to ffield
homes for their senior housing project
the reserve the Reserve at hun trace and
to declare an emergency coming from
Economic Development committee
and um yeah this is just to um allocate
money just like it says to Fairfield
homes and their project on Lincoln
Avenue I can add to that if you want Mr
chairman please so uh if you recall um I
believe it was last year we allocated
money for Hunter Hills Apartments uh
they applied for State funding and
didn't not receive that
funding uh they have received funding
for the new development of 95 Senior
Living uh Apartments Assisted Living so
this funding has to be spent by the end
of this year uh as part of the uh
American Rescue plan it makes good sense
to Move It from the previous project to
this
project thank you any
questions councilman
you're
second Mich but something okay and
question oh I'm sorry I'm so sorry so do
you want something we do need to be
suped
on I don't know if
it's
ler they they do need to use it sooner
rather than later the auditor has asked
us that we have all ARP money dispersed
before the end of November I think the
deadline is Tech techically the end of
December but in order to account for you
know end of the year rush type stuff she
would prefer that we have it out there
I'm just I know we don't like by the end
of November already there needs to be
done it's been cash on hand that we've
been sitting on for quite some
time so I'm assuming you're not going to
suspend I just want to clarify council's
pleasure I mean suspension would allow
the project to move forward and get the
funding out there so
I would appreciate that if if Council
was willing so suspend okay we will
suspend all right thank
you any other questions comments thank
you next item is temporary resolution
11-24 a resolution to make
Appropriations from plan 2025 budget
expenses and other expenditures of the
city of Lancaster for fiscal year
2025 and to establish a line item
transfer Authority for All City
departments uh this is coming from the
finance
committee and I'm going to defer to the
mayor or service safety director for
comments yes Mr chairman um this is the
first draft of the
2025 budget
um we wanted to get that out to you
allow for a first Reading and Review uh
there will be some changes made uh
probably second and third reading um
I've already received input from a few
Council people sat down with uh Mr
wolfinger uh and others and uh we are
sitting down in the midst of sitting
down with all department heads and going
through the budget literally line by
line and uh where you don't see notes uh
if there's changes we're going to be
including notes so that you know what
those changes are and I would encourage
um
chairman and chairpersons of each
committee uh as you uh move through the
budgeting process address those things
at your committee or if you want to make
a call to to Carrie or I or um a
department head feel free to do that um
this is again the first draft of the
budget as you can see we're talking $190
million so it's a big undertaking we
wanted to get it in now to allow for not
only uh the full three readings but uh
if we would need to we can we would have
room to time to table and
discuss now I was wondering if uh this
will probably be tabled or you thought
about trying to pass it before the last
minut of the year which has been
tradition or just leave it to where how
the budget
progresses C certainly if necessary we
can do that I expect to have answers for
all questions pretty much handled by the
time the third reading comes along uh
but we did build in extra time to table
and and pass at the final meeting of
2024 if necessary okay uh committee
chairs how do you want to proceed with
with the budget do you want to work with
each of your within each of your
committees and whatever is covered in
the budget or do you want to go ahead uh
thank you Mr chair as speaking only for
the Safety Committee um I know I'm sure
this is something that we would very
much like to discuss I know uh the
safety at least the safety service
forces here within the city um have had
um some attention as well in this budget
so you know I I know there's going to be
some discussion from our committee on
the subject so that's most I'm going to
say about that at this
time other
councilman let me can I clarify Council
council member wol or chair wolfinger um
is is your question whether or not that
there would just be individual vetting
within the Committees at first and then
a full vetting with the council as a
whole is that what we're looking at well
yeah I want first of all the first step
is to determine whether the Committees
want to take responsibility and
accountability for each of your
particular uh departments that you work
with and pending where that goes um I'm
perfectly happy of committee amount of
time to review the entire business
budget all at once however if we have a
budget item area category that's pretty
straightforward I'm not sure we really
need to commit a lot of time so it's up
to each of you to outline not only your
committees but any questions you have on
the entire budget as it plays
out so we have a committee meeting this
week we can talk about ite meeting
public so and I believe the last meeting
in December I don't think we have a
meeting until after the budget's passed
if iall so we only need to have a
discussion this
Friday we can so and then Safety
Committee I think we meet before the
budget's
passed
de we do and I also plan to reach out at
the Safety Committee members and the the
mayor's office as well as the Chiefs to
see maybe if there's any interest in a
special safety committee meeting just
for the sole purpose of discussing the
budget and nothing more beyond that
happy to receive any feedback on that
please thank
you thank you now I fully intend I've
been going through the budget already
line by line I've done that one time and
I'll continue to do it each time but I
want the the committee chairs to take
their accountability for their own
departments and and if it cannot be
resolved you still have concerns with
Administration uh we get one by of the
Apple if you will uh once the budget's
passed everything is is available to be
spent by uh the administration and the
Departments and I just want to make sure
everybody has an opportunity to voice
their opinions and we'll see how it goes
this is my first budget rodeo and I
think it's the first budget for many of
you including the mayor and service
safety director other than the ones you
prepared your for your Police Department
so why don't we uh approach it that way
and then after we get to the second
reading uh we'll re reconvene and by
that time You' each would have had your
meeting I hope um and give me minutes or
thoughts and I'll add it to the to the
master good any other
questions thank you very much um next
item is uh temporary resolution
11-24 a resolution to appropriate from
the unencumbered balance and amend the
certificate of Appropriations with the
county auditor in the general fund 101
001 uh for County Auditor real estate
settlement fees uh that's coming from
Finance obviously and I'm going to refer
to auditor Nettles to
explain what you like to accomplish well
when I did the budget this time last
year of guessing how much the city of
Lancaster or how much farful county is
going to charge us to process the real
estate tax settlements um I erroneously
guessed in the middle between 2022 and
2023 is collection and O was off so um
2022 came in at
82,800 and 2023 came in at 56,000 so I
guess 70 and it's kind of off by $7,500
so I need to appropriate those monies so
I can get my um settlement fees out of
the red because they keep that cash and
I just have it's a booking entry so I
just don't know from year to year what
they're going to
charge okay and I assume you would like
to only have two readings to get this
that would be council's pleasure because
that would get me out of the red for the
end of October and councilman aers
you'll be my second yes sir thank you I
assume there's no more questions or any
questions thank
you that's it for the resolutions we're
moving on to the
ordinances uh of which the first one is
temporary ordinance
34-24 and ordinance to authorize the
amendment of The Joint uh Economic
Development District contract between
the city of Lang and violet Township and
to declare an emergency coming from
Economic Development Committee U
councilman who um
would like to sure that yeah so um as we
just spoke about briefly the city has a
Jed with Violet Township um we entered
into that back in
2023 and um the Jed was originally just
on land that was owned by Violet
Township uh however there is a nearby
property owner and business owner who
would like to become a part of the Jed
and so in order to do that we have to
amend the Jed contract in order to allow
them to get the benefit of being in the
Jed so this um ordinance is just to
allow us to amend that contract to allow
them to enter into the joint Economic
Development District um and we're on a
parallel timeline with Violet Township
as to how this is getting done um so if
we could just keep everything as it is
moving forward I would really appreciate
it it would benefit us and them as well
thank
you and three readings three readings
okay and
yours second councilwoman crates okay
thank you any
questions we'll do three readings on
temporary ordinance
34-24 uh next we have temporary
ordinance
35-24 an ordinance to repeal Langster
codified ordinance ordinance part one
Administrative Code Title Five
administrative chapter 139 public
transit Board of codified ordinances of
the city of Lancaster uh another one
coming from the law
committee yes thank you um this one and
the next one are just to clean up the
code this one's related to the transit
operations that transition to the county
as of July and now that we don't have
that department it's to remove that
section um and then the next one is to
clean up the code related to private
police and medical services that we no
longer contract
with okay and you are my second on this
one three readings and Mr skover is my
second on the next okay and you three
readings on both yes please okay any
questions okay okay then we'll go three
readings on
35-24 and three readings on
36-24 moving on we now have uh temporary
ordinance
37-24 an ordinance to accept the final
plat ldg development Emerald Place
project and you declared an emergency uh
coming from code enforcement and zoning
committee uh councilman alers yeah so we
are we just need to approve their final
PR plat because they had to dedicate a
right away so that they could get a
turning lane in if our city planner
she's here tonight and so she could give
us some updates I know ldg is a planned
mix facility of different sort of
housing Styles so if she just wants to
give us a quick jog or memory on what it
was again okay good evening um so this
ordinance is just for city council to
accept the final plat for ldg
development for the Emerald Place
project uh Emerald Place is not a
subdivision however they're dedicating
RightWay to the city of Lancaster which
will involve a lot split and
improvements of roadway thereby
requiring them to follow the subdivision
uh
codes um the Planning Commission
unanimously voted to approve LG's final
plat on September 12th with the
condition that all requirements laid out
by the city engineer um would be met so
the developers have complied with
everything that uh the city engineer has
required
and he h and the city engineer has
approved signing the myar so ldg is also
asking for this ordinance to be cleared
an emergency um they're trying to meet
an end of the year deadline to start con
construction and uh Zach Linsky from ldg
is here if anyone has any questions for
them as well any
questions no I have one question how
many apartment units will that be I
believe it was
20 216 216 thank
you would just one quick question would
suspension help since they're trying to
get it done by the end of the year I
know I typically I'm not a fan of
suspension but just wanted to throw that
out there just to see your opinion on it
um that's up to your discretion I think
they would be definitely for that if
that's what you would
like law director Would we not probably
have to like go three readings on this
because it's a change to the yes it's a
change to the plat and then also I'm not
sure so while we have what we believe is
the final plat I'm not sure if Kurt and
Engineering have signed off on
everything completely yet we signed the
M I think okay we'll leave it at three
readings but okay for now can we thank
you sorry
no my second will be uh council member
lenberg and we're going to go through
Reading thank you very much any other
questions thank you uh temporary
ordinance
38-24 an ordinance to repeal and replace
Lancaster cified ordinance part s
business regulations code chapter
751 pedlers coming from law director
councilman CH yes thank you um this is
going to update the code to require
criminal background checks for
charitable and religious vendors and
solicitors and it expands the time for
which the background check is valid from
30 days to one year and updates the fees
to align with more modern day clerical
costs um law director Hall I don't know
if you have anything additional you
wanted to add nope I think you covered
it thank you thank you um Mr bisj will
be my second and it'll be three readings
three readings great any questions
clarification we'll do three readings on
temporary resolution
38-24 temporary resolution
39-24 an ordinance to repeal and replace
Langs for cified ordinance part nine
streets utilities and public services
code uh Title One streets and sidewalks
chapter 903
sidebo uh law director or I mean law
committee crates again yes uh this will
update the code regarding micro Mobility
devices to include electronic or E
versions and to prohibit their use on
the sidewalks of the central business
district for public safety reasons it
also reduces the criminal penalty for
violations uh you will be my second on
that and and it'll get three
readings thank you
questions we will go three readings on
temporary ordinance
39-24 that's all the legislation I have
for this evening now any uh departmental
updates I hear none thank
you uh tonight's meeting prep uh
president Porter
thank you um chair wolfinger um we will
have our uh special council meeting on
October 21st for our training this was
rescheduled I I appreciate everybody's
patience in the fact that we had to
reschedule that we will be doing a
budget training and then we will do a be
doing a strengths and opportunities
analysis um to um determine you know
direction for the coming year so that'll
be that um and then it looks like um
temporary resolution
10624 star will be presented to correct
a typing
error who put
that you had a meeting um two meetings
in July we only have one oh you're
Crossing off the second meeting okay
thank you yeah that was my bad I'm sorry
no that's I just neglected to delete one
all good no I thought you I didn't mean
I I had I just didn't know that's okay
we're all good well we can have another
meeting that's all right yeah well
okay and then that's it for your report
that's it and uh any other items for the
finance committee to talk
about well I would entertain a motion to
adjourn it a motion to adjourn
second motion and a second uh roll
call yes yes yes yes and yes uh the
meeting is adjourned thank
you the regular uh Lancaster City
council meeting will convene at
6:30 hi this is Larry wz with olive Dale
senior citizens of Fairfield County our
mission is to provide an atmosphere for
friendships and feeling of connection
with others to help achieve our mission
we rely on local sport which is why
we're honored to once again be a
recipient of Buckeye cares program this
month Buckeye Toyota and Buckeye Honda
will make a donation with every vehicle
sold thank you Buckeye for all your
ongoing
support the Frankie Smith Funeral Home
in cremator in Lancaster and the Johnson
Smith Funeral Home in Baltimore have a
long and wonderful history of serving
our community feel free to give us a
call at 7465
3652 stop in and see us at either of our
two locations 405 North Columbus Street
in Lancaster and 207 South Main Street
in Baltimore respect for tradition
regard for change
[Music]
e
e e
if you please rise if able and join me
in prayer God grant us the serenity to
accept the things we cannot change the
courage to change the things we can and
finally the wisdom to know the
difference the October 14th 2024
Lancaster City council meeting is now in
session please join me in the Pledge of
Allegiance I pledge allegiance to the
flag of the United States of America and
to the Republic for which it stands one
nation under God indivisible with
liberty and justice for all
[Music]
sorry please call the role Mr alers here
Mr bisj here Mrs KES here Mrs hoop here
Mr lenberg here Mr skover here miss
tener here Mr Wing here and Mr wolfinger
here let let the record reflect there
nine members of Lancaster City Council
here for the meeting at this time I
would take a motion to excuse council
member alss so move second we have a
motion in a second to um to excuse
council member alss all those in favor
please say
I guess what you're getting embarrassed
I am well we have a cake for our
president I think there's two because Cy
got one too there's actually
three it might be concerned that no one
communicates around here well thank you
very much I appreciate that now we have
to sing to him well now we
everybody happy birthday to
you happy birthday to
you happy birthday dear
Jeff happy birthday to you thank you
very
much yeah I tried to shave a year off my
birthday and one of my friends called me
out so um yes thank you I was 54 yet
yesterday so thanks a lot yeah old 64 64
yes no I heard 34 so okay all right well
thank you everybody appreciate it we
will be celebrating some other birthdays
um on the 21st so we've got a couple
couple others to celebrate as well so
more cake yes and I will be providing
the cake so thank you all right um we'll
go to the reading and disposal of the
journal regular meeting minutes dated
September 23rd
2024 Mr President I'd like to make a
motion to receive and file the journal
second you have a motion second to
receive and file the journal all those
in favor please uh say I I all those
oppos same
sign we now move to the reports of City
officials email dated September 24
regarding finance committee minutes
submitted by Mr wolfinger email dated
September 27th regarding September
service committee minutes um submit by
Mr ALS email date is September 27th 2024
regarding water water pollution
committee September agenda and meet
meeting minutes submitted by Mr Wing
email dated October 1st 2024 regarding
this the city import authorities
finalization of the prepaid gas deal
submitted by the law director Hall email
dated October 1st 2024 regarding
September income collections uh
submitted by Tax Commissioner Hamilton
email dated October 2nd 2024 regarding
Safety Committee me meeting agenda
submitted by Mr bizjack email dated
October 7 2024 regarding reschedule
Council training submitted by President
Porter email dated October 7 2024
regarding October domestic violence
Awareness Month um submitted by
President Porter email dated October 8
2024 regarding 2025 budget submitted by
safety director Woody email dated
October 12th 2024 regarding finance
committee an agenda submitted by Mr
wolfinger in email dated October 13 2024
regarding address train should emitted
by Mr Wing I don't know if I needed to
write read that one but okay I wrote it
thank you very much Mr President I'd
like to make a motion to receive and
file the reports of City officials
second we have motion second to receive
and file the reports of City officials
all those in favor please say I I post
same sign we'll now move on to
Communications voicemail dated September
23rd 2024 addressing Council of a flyer
he received on his car from luster
Singleton um email dat is September 27
2024 regarding a notice that Keith mger
has sent a council email dated September
26 30th of 2024 regarding a public
request from Dan
tuto email date is September 27th and
the 30th of 2024 regarding an unreadable
email due to it advised not to open the
email of an unknown attachment submitted
by
5302 email dated October 3rd 2024
regarding warranty deed lanter Port
Authority submitted by Lori ker with
fairall County Auditor's office email
dated October 4th and the 10th of 2024
regarding lster
explicit drag shows submitted by Alicia
Curry and answered by law director Hall
email dated October 10th 20124 regarding
an unreadable attachment to settlement
report on September submitted by Britt
lawn Mr President I'd like to make a
motion to receive and file the
communications second have a motion
second to receive and file the
communications all those in favor please
say I I all those oppos same
sign somebody
it oh okay good all right um we now move
to special presentation and awards I
have none this evening petitions and
memorials there are no petitions or
memorials this evening at this time we
reached the uh portion of our agenda for
permission of Voters and taxpayers to
address Council are there any
individuals here this evening that would
choose to address
Council thank you sir um the rules are 3
minutes as you know name and address on
the sheet in front of you good evening
members of council I appreciate again
the opportunity for myself as well as
anyone to come and speak before you um
president Porter I apologize that
apparently your birthday is not as
interesting as drag shows but I wish you
a happy 54th birthday um I'm here today
to talk about uh something a little less
heated than the last number of weeks um
something with which I think most
everyone or everyone in this room agrees
which is safety for our citizens namely
pedestrians bike riders people on
electric scooters people on mobile
scooters that aren't electric uh any
essentially multimodal type of transport
um this community has unfortunately a
severe lack of infrastructure which
provides safe passage for those
individuals whether it's as simple as
sidewalks bump outs chicanes any of the
other more uh recently adapt models
around the country and I'm here to again
Ask Council to give consideration to
that study after study shows that
improving the safety of transportation
for those individuals improves the
safety for everybody a 13-year study
found that in adding infrastructure for
bike Lanes which are physically
separated from driving Lanes there was a
44% reduction in traffic fatalities and
a 50% reduction in crashes which caused
injury and I think that as we continue
to expand our city we have the
opportunity to focus not only on moving
cars more quickly through our community
which leads to Deaths but we can focus
rather on ensuring that our citizens are
protected irrespective of the manner in
which they move through the city in
former life I was a nerd nuclear
engineer and uh for anybody here who has
any type of experience in that you know
that kinetic energy is based on velocity
squared so every mile hour that a car
goes faster significantly increases the
kinetic energy and kinetic energy is
what hurts people and what kills people
uh just this Friday there was a
pedestrian who was hit in a crosswalk
Crossing with the light obeying all
traffic laws and yet they were hit by
somebody who was in a hurry trying to
turn left and scooting between two cars
I focus on the fact that they were
injured and hurt
but I also want to focus on the fact
that they were obeying traffic laws but
that should not matter I want mistakes
made by people who do not obey traffic
laws whether they're in or out of a car
or whether they're a 10-year-old walking
to the park to not be a death sentence
and that's done through Hardscape that's
done through infrastructure that's done
through curbs that's done through things
cars run into that are people thank you
very much thank
you is there anyone else at this time
who would like to address
councel hearing none we're going to move
on with the rest of our
meeting reports of standing committees
finance committee minutes dated
September 23rd 2024 submitted by Mr
wolfinger Mr President I'd like to make
a motion to receive and file the reports
of standing committees second we have a
motion second to receive and file the
reports of standing committees all those
in favor please say I I all those oos
same
sign reports of special committees there
are no reports there are no public
hearings this evening we will now move
on to the reading of resolutions and we
have no third readings uh to begin with
we will move to Second reading beginning
with temporary resolution
10-24 a resolution to authorize the sa
service safety director to advertise for
bids and enter into contracts for mowing
and trimming the city cemeteries um this
is Public public Public Works committee
Mrs Miss tener and Mr lenberg council
member tener a second of three readings
please second of three readings on
temporary resolution
10124 temporary resolution
10224 a resolution to approve the city
of Lancaster Cedar Hill Neighborhood
area plan um code enforcement and zoning
committee Mr aers and Mr lenberg council
member aers this will be the second of
three readings second of three readings
on temporary resolution 102 24 a oh
sorry temporary resolution
10324 a resolution to authorize the law
director to negotiate and enter into a
contract with the city of Reynoldsburg
for the prosecution of adult misdemeanor
traffic and criminal
offenses committed in the city of
Reynoldsburg within farful County Ohio
and to accept payment um finance
committee with Mr wolfinger Mr alers
council member wol finger be second of
three readings second of three readings
on temporary resolution 10324 temporary
resolution 10424 a resolution to
authorize the law director to negotiate
and enter into a contract with the city
of Pickerington for the prosecution of
adult mrd meter traffic and criminal off
offenses committed in the city of piered
within Fairfield County Ohio and to
accept payment um finance committee with
Mr wolfinger and Mr alss council member
wolfinger second of three readings
second of three readings on temporary
resolution
10424 temporary resolution
10524 a resolution to authorize the law
director to negotiate and enter into a
contract with the fairford County Board
of Commissioners for the prosecution of
adult Mr meter traffic and criminal
offenses committed in The Villages and
unincorporated unincorporated areas
within fairfi County and to accept
payment um finance committee Mr
wolfinger Mr aers council member
wolfinger uh second of three rtings
second of three readings on temporary
resolution
10524 temporary resolution
10624 star a resolution to schedule the
schedule Lancaster City Council meetings
and finance committee meetings for 2025
law D or law committee with M Kites and
Mr wolfinger council member kites yes
thank you Mr President I would like to
make a motion to replace resolution
temporarily number 10624 by replacing it
with resolution 10624 Star as given to
the clerk in writing prior to tonight's
meeting second Motion in a second to
replace temporary resolution
10624 with temporary resolution 10624
Star as presented to the clerk and
writing before the commencement of this
evening's meeting any discussion no
thank you please call the rooll Mr aers
yes Mr bisj yes Mrs Cates yes Mrs hoop
yes Mr lenberg yes Mr skover yes M tener
yes Mr Wing yes and Mr wolfinger
yes temp resolution 10624 is replaced
with temporary resolution 10624 Star by
a vote of 9 to
Z council member
C it's the second of three readings
thank you sorry uh second of three
readings on temporary resolution
10624 star we'll now move to the first
reading of resolutions with the
temporary resolution
10724 a resolution to approve then
announc certificates for pay payment of
invoices to Shelly company out of the 3
M Street Improvement Levy fund 20009 and
the general Improvement fund 3016 and to
declare an emergency requested by Public
Works committee Miss Tiner and Mr
Luxenberg council member tener Mr
President I'd like to make a motion that
Council suspend rules and way the second
and third reading of temporary
resolution
10724 second so we have a motion a
second suspend the rules in way of the
second and third reading of temporary
resolution
10724 any discussion I'll wait thank you
please call the roll Mr aers yes Mr bisj
yes Mrs kit yes Mrs hoop yes Mr lenberg
yes Mr skun yes Miss tener yes Mr Wing
yes and Mr wolfinger yes motion to
suspend the rules and W the second third
reading of temporary resolution 10724
passes 9 to0 council member tener Mr
President I like to make a motion that
Council pass and gross and enter upon
the written record temporary resolution
10724 second we have a motion a second
to pass and gross and enter upon the
written record temporary resolution
10724 council member Tina yes this is
just to pay Shelly for the uh work they
have done with the street Improvement
okay thank you any further discussion
hearing none please call the rooll Mr
aers yes Mr bisj yes Mrs kites yes Mr
Mrs hoop yes Mr lenberg yes Mr skover
yes Miss tener yes Mr Wing yes Mr
wolfinger yes temporary resolution
10724 passes 9 to0 temporary resolution
10824 a resolution to appoint a business
representative to the board of directors
of the violent Township city of
Lancaster joint Economic Development
District requested by law law committee
Mrs Kites and Mr bisj council member
kites first of three readings first of
three readings on temporary resolution
10824 temporary resolution
10924 a resolution authorize allocating
American Rescue plan funds to Fairfield
homes for their senior housing project
The Reserve at Hunter's trace and to
declare an emergency requested by
Economic Development Committee Mrs hoop
and Mr Wing council member hoop yes Mr
President I would like to make a motion
that Council suspend its rules and wave
the fir the second
and third reading
of um temporary resolution
10924 second we have a motion a second
to wave the rule suspend the rules and
wave the second and third reading of
temporary resolution
10924 any discussion council member hoop
no thank you please call the role Mr
aers yes Mr bisj yes Mrs KES yes Mrs
hoop yes Mr lenberg yes Mr skover yes
Miss tener yes Mr Wing yes and Mr
wolfinger yes motion to suspend the
rules and mo the second and third
reading of temporary resolution 109 24
passes 9 to Z council member hoop um Mr
President I would like to make a motion
that Council pass and gross ner upon the
written record um temporary resolution
10924 second we have a motion second to
pass gross and enter upon the written
record temporary resolution 10924 any
further discussion no that we just
talked about this and finance thank you
hearing none please call the rle Mr aers
yes Mr bisj yes Mrs kit yes Mrs hoop yes
Mr lenberg yes Mr skover yes Miss tener
yes Mr Wing yes and Mr wolfinger yes
temporary resolution 10924 passes 9 to Z
temporary resolution
11024 a resolution to make the
Appropriations for plan
2025 budget expenses and other expens
expenditures of the city of Lancaster
for fiscal year 2025 and to establish
line item transfer Authority for All
City departments requested by finance
committee Mr wolfinger and Mr Al aers
sorry council member wolfinger first of
three readings first of three readings
on temporary resolution
11024 temporary resolution
11124 a resolution to appropriate from
from the UN incomer balance and amend
the certificate of Appropriations with
the county auditor in the general fund
10001 for the county auditor real estate
settlement fees requested
by the finance committee Mr wolfinger
and Mr alers council member wolfinger
first of two readings first of two
readings on temporary resolution
11124 we will now move on on to the
reading of make sure here make sure we
got it all yes we'll now move on to the
reading of ordinances beginning with the
third reading of temporary ordinance
3324 an ordinance to authorize the mayor
to acquire five permanent drainage
easements necessary for the East Main
Street sewer separation and and Court
drainage improvements phase one project
um requested by water water pollution
committee Mr Wing and Mr alss council
member Wing Mr President I'd like to
make a motion that Council pass and grow
and enter upon the written record the
ordinance is temporarily number 3324
second we have a motion in a second to
pass and gross and enter upon the
written record temporary ordinance
3324 any discussion yes Mr President um
as we previous previously discussed um
uh this allows the city to obtain uh
he's been on five separate properties on
the East Main Street and Court area for
uh drainage improvements and Sewer
separation purposes thank you any
further discussion hearing none please
call the RO Mr aers yes Mr bisj yes Mrs
K yes Mrs hoop yes Mr lenberg yes Mr
skover yes Miss tener yes Mr wolfinger
yes and Mr Wing yes sorry temporary
ordinance
3324 passes 9 to0 we have no reading
second readings of ordinances this
evening uh we will now move to the first
reading of ordinances with temporary
ordinance
3424 in ordinance to authorize the
amendment of The Joint Economic
Development District contract between
the city of Lancaster and violet
Township and to declare an emergency
requested by Economic Development
Committee Mrs hoops and Mrs Crites
council member hoop first of three
readings first of three readings on
temporary ordinance 3424
temporary ordinance
3524 in ordinance to replace Lancaster
codified ordinance part one
administrative code 12 Title Five
administrative chapter 139 public
transit Board of the codified ordinance
of the city of Lancaster requested by
law committee Mrs Kites and Mr wolfinger
council member Crites uh first of three
readings first of three readings on
temporary ordinance 3524 temporary
ordinance 3624 and ordinance to repeal
Lancaster codified ordinance part one
Administrative Code Title 5
administrative chapter
130 uh service Safety Board of the
codified ordinances of the city of
Lancaster requested by law committee Mrs
Kites and Mr skover council member KES
first of three readings first of three
readings on temporary ordinance
3624 temporary ordinance 3724 an
ordinance to accept the final plot for
ldg developments Emerald Place project
and to declare an emergency requested by
code enforcement and zoning committee Mr
aers and Mr lenberg council member alers
this will be the first of three readings
first of three readings on temporary
ordinance
3724 temporary ordinance 3824 an
ordinance to repeal and replace
Lancaster codified ordinance part 7
business Regulation Code chapter 751
Peddlers requested by law committee Mrs
crates and Mr bisj council member crates
first of three readings first of three
readings on temporary ordinance
3824 temporary ordinance 3924
and in ordinance to repeal and replace
Lancaster codified ordinance part nine
streets utilities and public services
code Title One streets and sidewalks
chapter 903 sidewalks requested by law
committee uh Mrs crit and Mr wolfinger
council member CH first of three
readings first of three readings on
temporary ordinance
3924 that concludes our reading of
ordinances this evening and we will now
move to tabled legislation there being
none um any council members have any
unfinished business this
evening hearing none any new business uh
to come before Council this
evening hearing none we will now move to
announcement of scheduled meetings
October 28th at 6:30 p.m. um November
4th at 6:30 pm both here in this room so
those are the the those are the regular
Council the regular Council meetings I
apologize special scheduled meetings
upcoming special meetings a special
council meeting Monday October 21st at
6:m at City Hall 1897 conference room
thank you regularly scheduled committee
meetings um we have UPC upcoming
committee meetings Public Works October
18th at 7:30 a.m. City Hall 1897
conference room Finance um committee
October 28th at 6:00 p.m. in council
chambers Economic Development October
31st at 7:30 a.m. City Hall 1897
conference room reading of bills um mnco
there's one this evening for
$177
43 Mr pres I like to make a motion to
pay the bill second no motion second to
pay the bill uh all those in favor
please say I I all those opposed same
sign thank you uh no executive session
needed this evening at this time at
6:55 I would ask for a motion to adjourn
regular Council Mr President I'd like to
make that motion we adjourn
second all those in favor please say I I
all those oppose same sign thank you
everybody this meeting is adjourned uh
please sign your legislation before you
would leave this evening
[Music]
for